jason weyman acuna might be the most
recognizable member of the jackass cast
but this skateboarder's got some tricks
you haven't seen and some tacos you have
to try
jason acuna's father george served in
the united states army and was stationed
in germany when he met and married
acuna's mother the couple was
transferred to a base in pisa italy
while his mother was pregnant though
english is his first language acuna's
mother taught him german as a boy and he
remains fluent in the language he told
stevo on the stevo wild ride podcast you
know when you're a kid and you're asking
your mom what's this
my mom would tell me in german and i'd
be like no not that funny language
eventually acuna would settle in
southern california where his father's
family is from and as a pre-teen he
became heavily involved in the area's
skateboarding culture
when he was born the delivering doctor
noticed that jason acuna's head was
large compared to the rest of his body
concerned that the baby might be
hydrocephalic the doctor ran tests and
determined that acuna instead had a
genetic condition known as
achondroplasia which causes dwarfism as
a boy acuna's mother took him to an
annual conference sponsored by the
support group little people of america
thinking that he might enjoy meeting
other children with dwarfism acuna felt
differently however telling the new york
times in 2022 i came back and i go mom i
don't want to go to these things anymore
i'm like that's not what my life is
about he compared the impulse to group
people with dwarfism together to the
idea that a bald man should be friends
with other bald men he's a dude he's a
jogger he wants to hang out with other
joggers skateboarder hang out with
skateboarders
as a young skateboarder in torrance
california in the late 1980s and early
1990s jason acuna began attracting
attention in his interview with the new
york times he said he was already being
sponsored by local skate shops at age
14. at the time the local torrent
skateboard company was world industries
and acuna and his friends would try to
score free merchandise at the company
warehouse opened in 1987 by professional
skateboarders steve rocco and rodney
mullen world industries build itself as
the first skateboard company operated by
and for skaters the story goes that
steve rocco's brother sao gave a cuny
his nickname shouting hey everyone we
man is here whenever a cunha would come
around a few years later world
industries magazine big brother
published a photo spread featuring acuna
and printed the nickname after that wee
man was his official stage name
much of the groundwork for what would
one day become jackass was late at big
brother magazine the publishing arm of
world industries started by steve rocco
in 1992 the magazine embraced its parent
companies for us bios ethos and ran
skateboarding interviews and photo
spreads alongside features and humor
pieces that were unpolished irreverent
and raunchy in other words it was
jackass before jackass acuna got a job
in the office by virtue of being local
and hanging around so much that editor
and future jackass director jeff
tremaine finally just put into work when
big brother released its first video a
skateboarding compilation acuna appeared
on the box arc covered in blue paint
there's an egalitarian streak that runs
through the two plus decade run of
jackass everyone suffers on camera at
some point and everyone is the butt of
the joke over the years many of acuna's
stunts and pranks have been no different
from the ones performed by knoxville or
the rest of the cast but many of his
best and most memorable stunts came from
the unique opportunities afforded by his
height acuna was often paired with cast
member preston lacey as their two polar
opposite body types complement one
another to comedic effect
because of his stature jason acuna is
the most recognized jackass cast member
even more so than knoxville his fame is
inescapable and he estimates that he's
been recognized on the street nearly
every day since the show premiered in
the year 2000. over the years zacunia
has avoided the tabloid attention that
some of his castmates have faced in fact
he has discovered that the name we man
serves a useful role in delineating
those people who want to be his friend
from those who simply want proximity to
fame speaking to genco magazine about
romantic relationships acuna said no
chick has ever called me wee man that
i've dated i've also never dated a chick
that i noticed would call me wi-man
because it didn't feel like she was
trying to date me
so if he's not wasting it on the spoils
of fame what does jason acuna do with
his money in 2008 he became an investor
in the california-based mexican
restaurant chain chronic tacos opening a
franchise in redondo beach called
weman's chronic tacos the chain was a
good fit for him not just because of the
rock and roll street art aesthetic of
its locations but also as a connection
to his father's family which is of
mexican descent
in 2012 jason acuna took a rare leading
man role in the family christmas comedy
elf man when a little girl makes a wish
on an old elf doll to bring her father
home on christmas eve a magical elf
played by acuna appears to make the wish
come true by morning when santa will
bring him back to the north pole little
do they know that the little girl's
father has been kidnapped by a group of
thieves seeking his fantastic new
invention when the thieves attack the
house the elf must defend the family by
believing in himself and becoming the
christmas superhero elf man the film was
released direct to video and was not
terribly well received the most positive
review might be this youtube video
featuring the children of acuna's
jackass castmate dave england i thought
it was really funny that
the robbers were
not very smart
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
jackass are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you